you
we're in the Parnell's Center for the
Arts the exclusive home to the school of
drama which is one of the nation's
oldest degree-granting drama
institutions I'm sitting on the stage of
the Phillip Shaw ski theatre which is
the main performance space for drama
majors each year 526 Broadway caliber
shows are performed in this space
options in the School of Drama include
acting design directing dramaturgy music
theatre and production construction of
the Parnell's Center was funded almost
entirely by donations from school of
drama alumni so notable alumni include
Ted Danson Holly Hunter Zachary Quinto
Rob Marshall blair Underwood and Stephen
Schwartz